and so it begins hey we put it down a
challenge for some picky picky eaters
sardines is up today chopping down I
think best sardines is an acquired taste
today our briny little suckers and they
will give you a one-two punch oh of
Labor and fishy miss we call a fish with
no eyes I hear you have a certain non
proclivity for sardine canned fish it
just doesn't sound right to me I feel
like just this odor emanating from this
can of just gross little things I don't
like the little can they come in okay
everyone got beef all right like fish
have you ever had it fresh oh I have
sardines one time where are the bones
like the brains and the guts I don't
like any sort of seafood so you do not
like the taste of seafood no let's talk
about what do you like my favorite type
of food is Mexican food because it's
like spicy and cheese put together so
you like complex flavors I love like
really savory like mac and cheese like
these full flavors Italian food Mexican
food do you like spicy that can handle
some spice okay Tom I do not do spice
now you want to see me Potter hell out
we're not gonna yuck anyone else's YUM
and some people do think sardines are
yummy
we may not change overdone small hands
but my teachers we got this Lauren okay
we'll be back I don't wanna be here so
today I'm taking a traditional spin on
sardines which is it's often done like a
sardine toast but i'ma do sardine
tostada because I'm bringing in that
plant-based Caribbean
Sealand variation you know I always have
to take it to my left inside I'm gonna
be doing a crispy tortilla shell then
I'm going to take these cuties and I'm
gonna sautee them and make a red style
Bolognese or a red sauce so it's gonna
be my side fat Roja and then I'm gonna
layer that with some avocado with some
onions with some cilantro and with some
shredded gordita so that's flavor on
flavor on flavor on flavor everyone's so
afraid of using this right what they
don't know is that hiding right here so
right now I'm preparing just some garlic
and shallots for when I see my sardines
scoring up real nice get them real
crispy a little soy what that's gonna do
is bring out the saltiness the Amami of
sardine itself because it's very very
good fresh I'm from the Bronx and I've
been growing I've grown up with you cans
I've been eating these they were also
the star of many of my collegiate
struggle meals so if you know how to
mess with flavors what am I talking
about your flavor matrix salty sweet
sour tangy umami then you can just do a
variation that pulls out the flavors
that you want from that so right now I
have some sushi rice that I just made
seasoned here with some shoyu soy sauce
I'm gonna show you some flavors right
now I'm reducing some soy sauce mirin
garlic shallot tomatoes in the same oil
that I was frying the sardines in so
what that's gonna do is amplify the
amount of sardine taste in your mouth
the girl here got one two three what
cans of sardines I don't like I'll put
all the holes we are facing fears
head-on now you have starting a rice
ball with sardine mail I always say
people eat through their eyes so you
gotta also make it look visually
appealing sardines das I like it it's
white I don't taste any like fishy
flavor I'm really really impressed I
don't taste the sardines at all don't be
don't be sorry don't be afraid oh I
champion I like the flavor has a good
taste to it is this the only fish in it
like there's fish within everything else
too okay this man did I like it so out
of the two dishes i'ma have to go away
I'm a goalie Ross in this I'm a Bowie
dish number two because I just wasn't
expecting that and then how everything
came together vomits me if I had to
choose one of the two dishes I'm
definitely gonna go with yachties
tostada and I just couldn't tell that
there was starting in it at all so I
think that is a one in my book they were
both great but I think I have to go with
this number two just the fact that the
sardine was just right there in my face
it was a little scary but I wanted to
dig in I wanted to eat it
[Applause]
our goal here was to make you guys these
sardines and we did that the real winner
is sardines
Ross took it to another level we play
with lots of flavors you guys are all
now leaving there we say sardine
experimenters are open to try it we made
some changes guys Gardein all 2019
you